hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown a federal judge
in louisiana temporarily blocking the
biden administration's effort to allow
title 42 to expire a trump-era pandemic
authority allowing border agents to turn
away migrants at the u.s southern border
to protect public health chad wolfe
former acting homeland security
secretary under the trump administration
shares his thoughts on the order and the
us's current immigration policies
former pro wrestler and fox nation host
tyrus joins the rundown opening up about
his childhood what it was like being
rapper snoop dogg's bodyguard and his
new memoir just tyrus plus commentary by
fox news contributor and former utah
congressman jason chaffetz the fox news
rundown is a daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you could subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
i'm brett baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
bryan kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
friday april 29th 2022 on lisa brady a
new plan for the southern border but
will it make a dent in the migrant surge
unless they decide to change policy
they're going to continue to have an
operational tempo along that border
that is just trying to shovel the water
out of a sinking boat at the moment
i'm chris foster the pro wrestler and
fox news personality tyrus has a new
best-selling book about his life and
lessons learned it's not what you're
going through
it's your reaction to what you're going
through is how you're going to be judged
and remembered and so i lived that with
it's my reaction and that took all the
power away from the negative stuff when
and never accepting no
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's been a long week on capitol hill
for homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas defending the
administration's handling of the
southern border at a trio of house
hearings over two days we inherited a
broken and dismantled system that is
already under strain it is not built to
manage the current levels and types of
migratory flows only congress can fix
this also telling all three committees
that a six-point plan detailed this week
has been months in the making including
a surge in resources to help speed up
the processing and removal of migrants
as the agency and border communities
brace for a potentially bigger search
once title 42 is lifted the cdc says
that covid related order allowing many
asylum seekers to be turned away should
end next month the court has put that on
hold temporarily my constituents want
you impeached because they believe
you've committed treason
they believe you're a traitor colorado
congressman ken buck accusing mayorcast
of intentionally not enforcing
immigration laws a line of attack
repeated by many republican lawmakers
including ohio's jim jordan who says the
goal is to get as many illegal
immigrants into the country as possible
the chaos on our southern border is not
an accident
it's deliberate it's on purpose it's by
design republicans also hammering away
at concerns about crime terror suspects
and drugs white house spokeswoman
jensaki says they're willing to work
with any lawmaker there need to be fixes
at the border whether that is smarter
security funding or fixing the asylum
processing system that's long been
broken still mayorka says the border has
been effectively managed i think most
reasonable americans would say that
that's absurd he also talks about how
the border is still secure in his words
and that he has operational control of
that southern border chad wolfe is the
former acting homeland security
secretary and president of wolfe global
advisors which is just
it's absurd any any which way you look
at it or any metric that you look at so
when you have
221 000 illegal apprehensions you have
eighty percent of border patrol not on
the border and you have twenty to forty
maybe sixty thousand got aways in one
month alone that's not operational
control you do not have operational
control of the border
and it's certainly not secure we also
heard a number during the hearing of 42
known or suspected terrorists that they
have encountered so it's not secure and
i think he does a disservice
to the men and women of the department
and really hurts the credibility of the
department when he makes these
statements when
again most reasonable americans would
say it's not even close to be insecure
republican lawmakers
hit secretary mayorkas especially hard
during thursday's judiciary committee
hearing in the house saying he should
resign or even be impeached accusing him
of intentionally not enforcing border
security and suggesting it's treason is
that going too far
well here's what i'd say and here's why
they're concerned right because the
secretary keeps talking about they have
a plan and they're executing on their
plan but their plan for the last 15
months is to see historic numbers of
illegal apprehensions and if that is
their plan that they're executing on and
you have to assume it is then yes i
think that that is very worrisome that
the plan is to encourage historic
numbers
of individuals to cross that border
illegally and not put in a deterrent and
not build immigration enforcement
pathways to remove these individuals so
if that is truly their plan yes that is
concerning and i think you really need
to take a look at whether or not he's
doing his job that he took the oath to
do and that he's required to do by
congress you know if you look at the
2006 secure fence act there's a
requirement in there that he shall i
think is the words that they use
maintain operational control over that
border and if he has taken certain
positions
that undercut that or make it impossible
for his agents to have then he's
ignoring the law
if he did resign or he were to be
impeached though
would that just end up being another
hurdle taking time away from trying to
address what's happening on the border
well i think the bigger point maybe to
your question is if it's not secretary
mayorkus then it's someone else right
and it's someone else that has the same
position that the white administration
does so i think most congressional
republicans are frustrated because
they're not getting clear answers to
their questions the secretary's very
good at filibustering a question during
a hearing and not being forthcoming and
not being transparent they're frustrated
about that they're frustrated about the
situation on the border and the fact
that after 14 months it's not getting
it's not improving but then to have the
secretary to say it's under control and
it's you know it's a secure border
they're not being truthful so that's
their frustration at the end of the day
but the concern is you know you put
someone else in there doesn't get any
better and i don't know that it does
under this administration and unless
they decide to change policy they're
going to continue to have an operational
tempo along that border
that is just trying to shovel the water
out of a sinking boat at the moment
to play devil's advocate for a minute
the administration regardless of the
numbers would likely say no we don't
have some
plan to try to let as many illegal
immigrants into the country as possible
so from that standpoint is that a
dangerous argument for republicans to be
making because to a lot of americans it
might sound more like a conspiracy
theory
i don't think it is a conspiracy theory
i know i know it's it's almost
unbelievable
right so some people would say it's so
unbelievable that that can't be reality
and if it's not reality then yes you
know perhaps it is a conspiracy theory i
i don't think that's the case because i
think you have to you have to take them
on their work you look at 14 months of
historic illegal immigration
historically legal apprehensions and
historic number of got aways and deaths
in custody and on and on and on and then
the secretary will say that we have a
plan and we're executing on our plan and
so the question is if the plan isn't
what it appears to be then what is the
plan and
is the plan to enforce the law along
that border because for 14 months that's
not the case
and so i think they're asking some very
basic questions up there which is if
you've got a plan to get this under
control a what is it and how long does
it take i mean i've been in the seat
it's hard but you have to make hard
decisions if congress isn't going to act
you can't always rely on congress to act
and so you have to start using your own
authorities to do certain things that
are hard decisions and we don't see any
of that coming from this administration
so if they decided not to do that
then the plan that they say they are
executing is the plan that you see today
and that plan results in historic
numbers of individuals coming across
that border that are released into the
country
what about this new six-point plan that
includes things like sending hundreds
more agents to the border and increasing
enforcement of deporting migrants who
don't qualify for asylum and detaining
single adults
can that be effective in your opinion
i think that plan is more smoke and
mirrors than anything else i think it
was released a day before the secretary
had three different congressional
hearings as a way to blunt some of the
criticism
there's nothing new in that plan it's
everything that they should have been
doing since day one it's all authorities
and it's all programs that are in place
today it's it's all of those things we
were doing in the trump administration
and more
so this idea that you're going to roll
this six-point plan out and say well
this will solve the problem it won't
it hasn't solved it from day one of this
administration and frankly it didn't
solve it under the trump administration
we did all of those things you know
working with central america expedited
removal i think is in that plan and it
helped marginally but it did not solve
the problem that's why we had to come up
with things like remain in mexico and
the asylum cooperative agreements and
other programs that have been dismantled
because what we saw was the normal
run-of-the-mill everyday
programs that that are outlined in that
plan that frankly the obama
administration used trump administration
and now biden
simply don't work they're not going to
get you out of the level of crisis that
we are in at the moment
they've taken us to such a dramatic
place
it takes dramatic measures to get out of
this and these you know that six point
plan is simply not it
two policies that started during the
trump administration remain in mexico
and title 42 that covet era rule
are essentially tied up in court right
now
how much of
an additional surge do you
think is coming for instance if and when
title 42 is actually lifted
and how much time is actually needed to
really be ready for that
well a couple points on title 42 i think
you hear a lot about you know from the
administration and some of that is in
that six point plan talking about
surging resources i think you mentioned
that right and he mentions that in his
plan and when you do that you're simply
managing the crisis you're not trying to
solve the crisis you're actually just
trying to facilitate quicker processing
into the country and that's just going
to facilitate more and more individuals
coming into the country it's a demand
signal uh you're signaling that if you
come to the border and you cross
illegally we're simply going to process
you quicker to get you to your final
destination so there's no deterrent in
that and so i would say that their whole
strategy is the wrong strategy and i
don't think anyone expects them to go
from historic you know numbers to
dramatically low numbers but you would
see slow improvements
instead it almost is almost every month
is getting worse and worse and worse so
it's clear their their plans
not working at the end of the day but if
you remove title 42 i think you will see
a surge and i think the secretary talks
about this either in his plan or public
hear recently that they started planning
in september of 21 for the removal of
title 42 right so that's six months what
they should have been doing is say okay
title 42 is going away i need to come up
with new policies and new programs that
deter
that root out fraud in the in the
silence system and do a number of things
to address the surge to counteract title
42 but they're not doing that
you've got to you've got to do something
dramatic to get us out of where we're at
now and i don't you got to bring
deterrent back to the system and you got
to hold people accountable who choose to
break the law and not think that
everyone who applies for asylum is going
to be granted asylum which is a system
that they have built
i wanted to ask you about the recent
death of a texas national guard member
who was trying to rescue migrants in the
rio grande river those migrants now
accused of being drug smugglers um his
death led to another tug of war
basically on the border security issue
the white house saying you know well
texas sent the guard to the border texas
saying we wouldn't have to if the
federal government was doing its job but
you know my question is are these kinds
of arguments
counterproductive to actually improving
anything and it's you know what's it
going to take to actually
get congress to make a move and agree on
something well you know first obviously
my thoughts and prayers go out to his
family but second i would say it's a
needless death it should never have
occurred because the federal government
should be doing its job at the end of
the day so the national guardsmen there
or texas department of public safety
shouldn't be on that border and
enforcing the sovereignty of that border
that is a role for the federal
government to roll for border patrol but
they have been told to stand down
so i appreciate your question which is
well you know the bickering back and
forth isn't helpful i don't think that's
the question the question is why isn't
the federal government doing its job
and you can't just say well if federal
government's not doing it no one's doing
it and so that's just how it's going to
be and i think what the governor of
texas has said is that's not good enough
for my constituents and the people of
texas and texans that if the federal
government's not going to do their job
and protect our communities then we're
going to have to step up and do it so
you have when you have no operational
control of the border when you have no
process in place this is the result of
it and it's it's tragic absolutely but
why did this happen why was a national
guard been put in a place where they had
to be patrolling a part of the river to
begin with and it's not just because
texas put them there it's because the
sovereignty of that border was being
abused there's no other country in the
world that treats their borders the way
that we do on our southern border they
actually patrol their border and they
stop individuals from crossing that
border that are legally entering the
country
but we seem not to do that
chad well former acting homeland
security secretary and president of wolf
global advisors we're always thankful
for your time thank you
okay thank you
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary coming up
tyrus has a lot to say and gets to say
it as a fox news personality co-hosting
his own podcast harrison timf and on
shows like gut felt here questioning the
need for the word marijuana to be
replaced with cannabis in washington
state laws over concerns that marijuana
has negative connotations i i just don't
understand this man marijuana never hurt
nobody it is the happy drug it is a
happy little plant you can't even say
marijuana in a bad way no you can't good
morning marijuana
hey chills he had a whole life before
coming to fox as a college and semi-pro
football player teacher bouncer and
bodyguard for the rapper snoop he's been
an actor and a professional wrestler
with the wwe tna and now the national
wrestling alliance before all that he
was an often homeless teenager from an
abusive home as a child you think about
it in your head and you replay things
and you kind of dumb it down and you
like you rationalize it you normalize it
his new book is called just tyrus a
memoir
when you're putting it on paper and
someone's reading it back to you
or someone's editing it it kind of takes
you back there and it was there were
some moments where i kind of just had a
difficult time writing the the childhood
piece it was a lot of that it's good to
go it's good to
go through the process of writing it
down i never i kind of scoffed at things
like that but it really helps and also
helps you put things in perspective
uh it was it was difficult but a good
difficult if that makes any sense it
does makes a lot of sense and i mean
like look you know that you pulled the
knife on your dad when you were four
years old and it's in your head
but reading those words like you said
did it seem like you or does it seem
like you when you when you have a memory
of something
it's through your eyes and then when you
write it down it's like you're the
narrator you're like you're looking down
on it and that was
that was different and this doesn't
sound weird but i made a joke out of
that story uh the part about
you know on tv when you stab a guy he
dies you know he just falls to the
ground and when i did that he was just
extremely pissed off so you kind of
laugh i mean you laugh at that but then
if you
read it where you're a four-year-old
who's
gone from hiding under the bed and
wetting himself because he's scared all
the time to trying to stab somebody it's
not as funny as you think so it's just
it's really i encourage anyone everyone
needs to write a book whether you
publish it or not just to get a better
understanding of yourself and kind of
bring yourself back down to earth just
hit a couple bullet points for people
who don't know how you grew up we grew
up in start inland massachusetts
just real quick see if you can
tell me about a couple minutes what your
life was like upstairs so i was my
parents my mother ran away from home she
was 15.
uh she met my biological father he was
19.
and uh she she went for playing barbies
to being a pregnant 15 year old who was
about maybe
90 pounds silk and wet
and this was the 70s in massachusetts
it was actually illegal at the time for
blacks and whites to get married in
boston white mom black dad yep
they moved them to new hampshire and i
was in i was born in uh
exeter new hampshire because
he wouldn't be arrested for one
statutory rape and two
which was the minor one like they
uh for the whole
um the man act of being black and her
being white so i was born there mike and
there's another thing my best guess was
that it was the city of lynn i knew i
was there for a time but we didn't move
around a lot and it it just went from
her being treated like a princess to
once i was born
that's when it became
uh violent yeah and then you
you had some adults in your life who
were who were good people and and maybe
not so good people and some people like
your mom
your mom comes off to me like someone
who's just trying to do her best yeah my
mother made decisions that as a child i
didn't understand and resented her for
it and she was making decisions
effectively as a child yeah as herself
but as an adult and as a parent
i get it now because i it's one thing i
say in the book is that she her always
her biggest concern was making sure we
were taken care of
that was more important to her than
anything else was going on i mean
there's one thing that you hear people
say i would never leave my children or
never give my children up
if it was the best
thing for your children i think it's
pretty selfless
yeah to do that and you can put the
negative spin on it but just think about
a mother who
has nothing and she's got to you know go
back to school and get her life together
and she couldn't do both so she had to
make a really tough decision and
her only thing was that we had to stay
together
me and my brother yeah so
um and you were she was back
she was out of your life she was in your
life she was almost like a friend for a
while yeah i think that's the best way
to describe so
just to kind of give you an idea when
when uh the abuse from my father
probably would still i don't think she
it would have been the death of her had
it not been turned on me and we talked
about the knife thing
with the attempting to stab him with the
knife
turned into one of the worst beatings of
my life and he was convinced that i was
not his child at that point and so then
which meant he was going to pass the
savings onto her but because he put
hands on me and was attempting to
basically throw me out a window of the
apartment that we were living in and she
talked him down but once he had put
hands on me that's what triggered her to
go enough i got to get out yeah and so
that's what that made the change but
unfortunately we got to my grandparents
house
and it being the time sign of the times
me and my brother were were just you can
stay but they can't um it's not all doom
and gloom but a lot of funny stories
um so let's get on to those uh you're a
bodyguard for a snoop for a while still
friends to this day right yeah um
bouncers and clubs tell us uh tell this
new story about uh you're on tour in
russia and the guy comes up claims to be
the best-selling rapper in russia
so
by this time i'm pretty much known for
my bluntness and i am the guy who ruins
everyone's day and i excel at it so
we're in russia and we're backstage and
snoop usually before he performs he
tends to like to like have a minute
alone to just kind of like get his
thoughts together come compress and get
ready to go uh entertain for two or
three hours or however long it was
and i he's not to be disturbed in this
time and i'm usually on the door for
that
and lo and behold here comes a guy who
no one could have wrote this guy any
better than he had a velvet suit on now
not not a jumpsuit a three-piece velvet
suit
and he comes up to me and he informs me
that he is russia's greatest rapper and
uh i need to meet with snoop and i said
oh man i'm sorry he's not seeing anybody
right now and then he reminded me who he
was
and it would be in your best interest
for me to see snoop because if not
you're gonna have a problem
it's day 12 of the tour okay and uh i
just didn't have time so what i did was
like okay look you got me bro
i'm the decoy he's not really behind me
he's down there
and i don't want any trouble so i will i
will take you to him and he said very
good you made you made a wise decision
you know i might have a job for you one
day i said oh
thank you
so as we walk to the thing as i open the
curtain there's a flight of stairs going
down and he looks down and as he went to
say there's no snoop there i threw him
into the darkness into the darkness and
as he tumbled down the stairs he could
have been an opera singer because he had
a really high pitched scream but his
shoes came off his purple shoes just
flipped off and
i closed the curtain and went back to my
spot so i figured he's going to be at
least down here for a while
and i remember the manager uh kevin
barkey comes up and his face gets he's
canadian and he is about the most
fair-skinned white guy on the planet and
whenever he gets frustrated his whole
face turns red uh and i see him with a
red face holding the shoe is like do we
need to talk about this and i just said
i would prefer not to
uh unfortunately he did sustain an
injury but
i did do my job and it kept him safe and
turns out he was uh he was a dangerous
character oh okay so i did the right
thing um
bouncer football player pro wrestler of
course
now you're uh now on fox
you write that a lot all those jobs have
something in common in that you want to
be prepared you want to be ready but
also leave some room for spontaneity
like your wrestling matches are
choreographed to a degree but within
that
you've got to have some room you've got
to play yeah you can't
there's
um i don't want to give away too much of
the magic show but there's two ways of
doing things there's spots and then
there's collet out there
calling it out there is the harder of
the crafts because you're basically
the you and your dance partner are just
going to work together
uh and just kind of play it by ear let
the crowd dictate it or you dictate the
crowd and
some things with camera angles and tv
you have to go over but
the best most easiest stuff is when
you're just like anything else if you're
trying to remember something it never
comes out right like if if you gave me
you were gonna ask me questions about
inflation and i had numbers in my head
and i would but i didn't really prepare
and i was trying to remember it my
interview's not gonna be very good when
you ask me the question wrestling is
very similar to that so
and the same thing with
acting and stand-up comedy you have to
prepare everything for me it started in
football it was film study you you do
the work on the field but it's not over
there then you got to go and like if you
put four hours in the field you got to
put three hours in the tape room
and wrestling was the same way you
always have to be i was always in film
study whether it was promos wrestling i
would pick a classic wrestler and i
would study him for a week and i'd try
to take a few things from here and there
fox a lot of our stuff is live and you
but and there's other people great minds
around you you've got about a minute a
minute and a half to get your point
across and
there's no oh i'd like to say this again
or oh if i could just have a few more
minutes no it doesn't work that way so
preparation is is for me is everything
and all the film study i probably watch
i would say probably four to five hours
uh a day of film just breaking stuff
down looking at different things getting
prepared a lot of it is the when i get
off when we finish filming gut filled i
go back to my hotel and i'm doing
news film study for probably two hours
each night because and then then i watch
myself back and like oh this uh you took
too long for that so it's it's all
process and they're all they're all
relatable in terms of preparation yeah
see i don't like hearing myself back i
know it's it's i hate the sound of my
own voice i hate it it's like i don't
think anyone who does but when i hear
myself talk all i hear is marbles so i
can't stand here in the sound of my own
voice but it's it's important in terms
of like being better
um one thing you kind of finish with is
this idea of being accountable and when
you're a kid
it was their fault it was their fault it
was their fault
but now as a as a grown up as a dad
um
you want to learn to own your own stuff
right and also and know yourself enough
that
not that you can't accept legitimate
criticism but know when that's invalid
and that you know what you're doing
right and the only way you can do that
is by being honest with yourself
my grandmother gave me really great
advice at a really rough time in my
childhood i was
dealing with some abuse with my uh
mother's
husband and i wanted to run away i
wanted to go back with them and
she basically said there's no escape and
it's not what you're going through
it's your reaction to what you're going
through is how you're going to be judged
and remembered and so i live that with
it's my reaction
and that took all the power away from
the negative stuff when and never
accepting no so if someone does
something bad to me
it's learning to
settle your differences inside and
owning
every job that i was fired from
or cut from football when uh my appendix
went out
i can look back and see things that i
could have done better and i focus on
that if i blame the coach for not liking
me he didn't like me he was hating on me
or whatever i will never get out of that
situation and that will become my golden
ticket of obscurity to where that is my
out for everything
so you use that out instead of going
look in the mirror going man you know
what if i was training better if i
wasn't out in the clubs those nights
maybe my you know the alcohol wouldn't
have affected my appendix the way it did
so you can look at things of what you
could have done better and react even if
there's a million people saying nope wwe
was wrong they did you dirty they fired
you it's my reaction and i was able to
pick up the pieces and move on if i
stayed there i'd still be there well the
title of the book just tyrus uh memoirs
good talking man congratulations thank
you so much man
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
one of the most recognizable outfits in
american movie history is headed for the
auction block the blue and white checked
gingham dress worn by judy garland in
the wizard of oz is quite the prize for
some lucky collector it's being
auctioned next month in bonham's classic
hollywood film and television sale but
the story behind the dress is a stunning
lost and found drama all its own there
were originally multiple dorothy dresses
made for the 1939 film and bonham's
director of popular culture helen hall
says that four of the dresses are known
to exist the one up for auction was
thought to be lost for decades at
catholic university of america in
washington d.c where it had been given
to someone in the drama department in
the early 70s and last year during a
decluttering of an office it was found
in an old shoebox
catholic university decided they'd
auction it instead of keeping it and
plans to use the proceeds to create a
full-fledged film program in the drama
department the less than archival
storage practice of the dress hasn't
seemed to hurt its value it already has
a pre-sale estimate of between eight
hundred thousand and one point two
million dollars
two of the four remaining dresses
including the one up for auction have
the blouse that was worn underneath it
the other one of those with a blouse
sold at an auction in 2015 for more than
a million and a half dollars aside from
a piece that's been cut away the dress
is in good condition and it's been
determined that judy garland wore it in
the movie in the scene where she is
confronted in a castle by a threatening
wicked witch of the west
if you don't have quite enough cash to
buy the dress at auction don't worry you
can still see a pair of dorothy's ruby
slippers at the smithsonian in
washington dc
where admission is free tanya j powers
fox news
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind long gone is the
democratic party of your parents
generation they have morphed and
contorted themselves into a political
party no longer relatable or
recognizable to most of america
today's democratic party embraces the
extreme rewards the radical shuns the
sensible and caters to the contemptible
not too long ago there were democrats
who were concerned about the finances of
the country
they were affectionately referred to as
blue dog democrats who were worried
about deficits and debt
there is no place for them in today's
democratic party
president joe biden and vice president
kamala harris just introduced the
largest budget ever with the largest tax
increase ever requested
there are very few blue dogs in congress
and they are on their way to extinction
leftist policies have become so extreme
even traditional liberals no longer
recognize today's democratic party
with never ending mass mandates
mandatory vaccinations and control of
individual self-determination
liberalism has been abandoned
today's democratic party prioritizes
illegal entry into the united states
while abandoning the rule of law they
fight for the suspected and convicted
criminals while ignoring the victims
often you will hear democrats refer to
rural america with contempt
labeling them as clinging to their guns
and their religion while simultaneously
lumping them together as uneducated
rarely do you hear them talk about
middle america nor express a genuine
understanding of what life is like
outside of new york washington and san
francisco
democrats are losing blue-collar workers
parents young voters hispanics etc
it is difficult to find an area of
growth for democrats today
it is the policy that is repelling the
voters inflation energy foreign policy
immigration taxes crime and extreme
positions on mass mandates gender and
education are all driving people away
from the democratic party
beyond the policy positions they also
lack dynamic leadership
clinton and obama were charismatic
personalities that brought people into
the party
not anymore
joe biden was supposed to be a uniter a
man with a plan and a seasoned senator
who could get things done in congress
none of those turned out to be true
combined with his poor communication
skills and a vice president who speaks
incoherently there is not much hope for
the democratic party's future
they have failed to build a bench of
upcoming leaders that relates to anyone
outside of new york and san francisco
with policy that lurched to the far left
and leadership that is aging out today's
democratic party is dead
while the leaders of the democratic
party wonder out loud why don't they
like us more
most americans understand today's party
no longer offers them a home i'm jason
chaffetz fox news contributor and the
host of the jason in the house podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes